persianas bajadas y calles silenciosas
casi dos semanas después de que los
talibanes tomaran el valle del panshir
bastión de la resistencia afgana los
pueblos están prácticamente vacíos
muchos residentes huyeron hacia la
capital
la gente estaba realmente asustada
temían que los talibanes los detuvieran
los golpearan o los mataran por eso
huyeron a kabul
los combatientes de la resistencia
prometieron luchar contra los talibanes
hasta el final y en los vehículos
calcinados de los islamistas quedan las
evidencias pero ahora los talibanes
patrullan las calles de la provincia y
controlan la entrada a la zona los
residentes aseguran que los talibanes
mataron a 20 civiles cuando llegaron y
que ahora las fuerzas extremistas no les
permiten salir de panshir
los combatientes insisten sin embargo
que los aldeanos están a salvo
nadie está molestando a la gente cuando
llegamos les dijimos que podían regresar
a sus casas que no les haríamos daño que
les daríamos seguridad la gente está a
salvo en las calles en los mercados no
hay amenaza
no está claro en qué situación está la
resistencia del panshir o si sus líderes
permanecen en el país los combatientes
se han ganado una reputación legendaria
por defender su pueblo del ejército
soviético durante una década durante la
guerra civil y durante el anterior
régimen talibán